I was shocked to learn though in your
life one of the great romances
was Stevie Nicks a Fleetwood Mac and I
this was very this was kept on the down
low even during your whacked out years
yeah but she says you were the love of
her life and probably still are she's
special did you guys ever write together
she helped me do the Confessor album no
kidding she wrote shotgun with me on
that one and gave me some direction and
she's really good at the craft of
songwriting which means what sitting
down and really putting a pen to paper
and actually trying to figure out the
lick and all that after my own devices I
will have
um 85 pieces of paper with a couple
words on each you two became this couple
and uh she says you are the love of her
life
all those songs were about Joe she wrote
one about me yeah what was the big one
about you uh
uh I'm trying to I'm embarrassed was it
a Fleetwood Mac song or was it from one
of her son of her solos one of her solo
albums yeah yeah
has anyone ever wrote a song for you the
hell no I wish you no that's how the
song goes oh what are you doing to
write a song about me listen to this
lyric
[Music]
oh don't you know that she'd rather be
alone
and be without you
were you in love with her
as a sister really God she was I mean I
imagine this is the 70s right I mean
she's she's like a soul mate you know
you still talk to her once in a while I
mean was there a more beautiful woman
than Stevie Nicks and all that talent I
mean you would think you would think
that's the whole package that didn't
come out right all I'm saying is that we
were
seeking Refuge kind of in each other's
presence because you both were into
drugs at that point kind of yeah there
was that part of it but uh we were on
the road we had careers
we're both lonely why did you never
marry her did the thought cross your
mind at one point no you never thought
that way even in terms of like a
powerful couple like oh my God there's
two incredibly powerful people in Rocky
maybe that would have been too much
well the the relationship
came and ran its course
as rock and roll relationships do does
it get competitive like do you sit there
and and she was in Fleetwood Mac at that
point I guess no she wasn't she was a
solo well she was in Buckingham next
yeah and and does it get competitive is
that the problem like you could never
really marry another singer-songwriter
because the two of you sit there and
drive each other nuts with that stuff
career no I don't think either of us
could could have committed to a lasting
relationship in this in the state that
we were in yeah what made it possible
was that we toured together
right so when you tour together and we
spent all that time together but you
were not monogamous with her because no
one knew back in those days you weren't
going to be limited to one drink and not
one woman you were an addict we were
both monogamous for that summer that's a
pretty long time yeah so you felt
something well in rock and roll that's
uh 10 years that's a long time when we
stopped touring uh we
drifted apart I had to yeah yeah I had
to
foreign